hey what's going on okay i see you in
the baron
i have not seen engine it since my
family upset her
but um i believe angenette will
understand
once she sees them there that they are
my family and
you know they they are a part of our
lives regardless if
we like them or not uh they're still
family
so uh these are my other other groomsmen
yeah yes
pedro
yeah it's like it's like a little bit
teens for you sure guys
guys is that a custom of the dominican
uh
no is that pedro's custom espedre
pedro's custom
okay i need some of those garter belt
for men
yeah are you guys ready yeah
uh we yeah getting ready to head down
now okay
oh yeah look at that look at the ladies
yeah yes looking good blue is my
favorite color in winter yeah oh great
i'm so happy looking good
fabulous follow you on
yeah looking good
that that's uh it's nice
when's the last time you wore a hoop
dress back in 1985
i mean 84. you think antoinette will
like this
i i don't know what the dress code is we
don't really but these we know these are
traditional who told you
right who told us yeah well everyone
everybody at the mall since i'm in the
philippines and my daughter-in-law
is a filipino it's important to wear
something traditional
my daughter-in-law hasn't told us
anything about
the wedding we asked other ladies what
to
wear and we were told these filipinas
which are these lovely big poofy prom
dresses
look like old lady dresses they do
like prom dresses from back in the 1980s
1918 or 1970s
1918. i don't i wouldn't know about that
i wasn't there
you